we begin with the race to slow down the
spread of the omicron variant here you
can see people lining up for testing in
florida in scenes that are a reminder of
the worst days of the pandemic the new
strain has been found in at least 38
states and this is what it looks like in
new york too where people are lining up
as you see their nate where the daily
positivity rate has doubled in three
days
people are a little worried here the cdc
is pushing again for people please get
vaccinated but it's no longer
recommending the one-shot johnson
johnson vaccine because of a link to
rare blood clots meg oliver reports on
the concern that stretches all the way
to the white house
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death
though reported omicron cases have so
far been mild experts warn every
precaution should be taken to prevent
infection if you have a lot of hospital
workers nurses and doctors and icu staff
calling in sick at home because they
have symptomatic covit that's going to
really tax an already strained health
system across the country many hospitals
are already at a breaking point due to
winter surges from the delta variant in
wisconsin just over four percent of icu
beds are available and in nebraska
frontline workers are overwhelmed i
would just hope that no one else has to
experience the things that we've been
experiencing meanwhile signs that
omicron is quickly spreading from coast
to coast new york city is now reporting
8 300 new cases a day leading to long
lines at testing centers and pushing
some companies like citibank to tell
employees to work from home the omicron
variant
is here in new york city in full force
in orlando florida omicron was found in
nearly 100 percent of the wastewater
samples taken this week just one week
after it was not detected at all dr
anthony fauci says there is good news at
this point there is no need for a
variant specific booster our booster
vaccine regimens work
against omicron this says new data
tracking the safety of the vaccines
showed that nine deaths due to rare
blood clotting have now been linked to
the johnson and johnson shot and not
just in younger women as originally
thought that information led the cdc to
recommend the pfizer and modern vaccines
over j and j on thursday
in response to the cdc's decision reps
for johnson and johnson say the company
remains confident in the safety and
durability of its vaccine and it will
collaborate with the cdc and global
health officials to educate the public
on the risks associated with it tony meg
thank you very much